crystal is with us in Richmond Virginia
hi crystal how are you Dave I'm doing
great happy to be with you today
you too how can I help so I am Dennis
just graduated in May and I have or had
three hundred thousand dollars in
student loans
thankfully I am part of the NHS feed
loan repayment program so I was able to
put thirty thousand on it you know this
month however my husband just started
physical therapy school and he's
obviously occurring dead so I'm just
trying to figure out we're in obviously
baby step two so just trying to figure
out whether I should just try and hit
mine or should I be thinking about some
of his interest since his loan is lower
just trying to figure out what's the
best way to do this so in a SP what you
say National Health Service Corps so
yeah so that's just working in an
underserved area doing dentistry and I
get thirty thousand a year for four
years towards my loans okay and what are
you making I make a hundred and twenty
five thousand a year okay or just yeah
okay and you have three hundred thousand
yeah so right now it's 277 because I
just paid some this man he has so much
so so far the principal is about twenty
three five twenty three thousand five
hundred and interest is another five
hundred how long before he's through
he just started so he has two more years
okay visit three-year program what does
he anticipate being paid as a PT I
believe it's about seventy I'm not a
hundred percent sure that was about
right that's about right I just checking
his reality scope here and what is he
spending to become a PT I think it's so
he's out of state so we'll see if he can
get in state but probably about 120
thousand by the time it's all said and
done
if we don't do intrest you know I'm not
really sure how the interest please into
that so that's what I'm trying to figure
out if we should just think about paying
interest on his so how much more to
graduate he needs to spend probably 100
little under a hundred thousand more in
two years yeah okay well the the first
step of getting out of debt is to add no
more to go no further in debt so that
leads me to say rather than reducing his
or yours substantially our first goal
would be to cashflow the remainder of
his school from your income and you can
do that okay so let's add let's do no
more harm since you're both in the
medical profession and let's go for no
further in and then yeah we'll go ahead
and take 120 during that time the credit
you're gonna get and then he comes out
and is making 70 at that point you're
making 200 plus as a couple and you will
have 300 or so in debt right yeah and so
we pay that off in three years okay a
year for three years is 300 right okay
so then you would so then we'd have to
save that so save up that money to be
able to pay his tuition no you make a
hundred twenty five thousand right use
your money okay I guess I'm just so used
to I'm sorry go ahead yeah you live like
broke college students because you are
right nothing exactly what we're doing
and then you throw all the money instead
of that loans you throw it at his and
you ought to be able to cash flow fifty
thousand a year for two years right out
of 125 that gets him through school with
no more debt did I do that right I did
so 50 a year out of your 125 gets him
through to school he's got 23 you go
three 277 that's 300 and loans that are
just sitting there during that time I
mean they're not just sitting there
you're paying something on them you're
required to patience right I mean
through the government program I'm gonna
have to put the other 90,000 to that
yeah
Oh to get your match you do yeah I have
to so that 90,000 that comes from the
government I'll have to put that
straight to my mother than your hundred
twenty-five thousand on her income
though right that's not including that
so you just take the government running
the government money you can't do
anything with it except though it on
your loan so by the way during this two
years you're going to get another sixty
and so you're not really going to have
to pay all three hundred you only got to
path to 40 right okay so when he gets
out both of you together are making if
he makes 70 and you make 130 that's two
hundred and when he's out and that's two
years from now and you've got two
hundred forty thousand dollars worth of
debt making to our thousand dollars a
year if you're not debt-free and two
years something seriously wrong okay two
and a half years you know so we're
talking about less than five years
you're 100% debt free but the first step
is adding no more debt do no more harm
cash flow is and you know what that's
going to do it's gonna make you look at
where he's going to school and how much
you pay for a PT to get a degree $70,000
your job that you pay him $50,000 for
the opportunity to do just the math on
it it's not a great deal so I'd want to
spend less than that to be a PT
personally but um you just look at it
I'm gonna telling you how to stop his
career field that's not it
but this idea that it's always worth it
because it's in the medical profession
it's just not true
I mean you spent a hundred and fifty
thousand bucks to get a $70,000 job that
doesn't make sense so I'm thinking where
he goes to school might get adjusted and
me making you pay cash for it's gonna
make you look at that